I have a bonafide bottom-of-the-barrel
vile and disgusting chrony swamp story
for you Equifax is own former lawyer is
going to be running the office that will
be in charge of investigating the recent
Equifax breach Equifax is one of the big
three credit reporting agencies along
with TransUnion and Experian and Equifax
had this massive data breach we learned
about it in September of last year it
happened sometime between May and July
of last year and the data of more than
145 million Americans was accessed by
cybercriminals credit card credentials
for some of those people were accessed
more general information for another two
and a half million people total
nightmare right my data was caught up in
the breach a lot of people's data caught
up in the breach really horrific Andrew
Smith has just been confirmed on a 100
percent party line vote by Republicans
to run the Federal Trade Commission's
Consumer Protection Office which will be
investigating the Equifax breach he used
to be Equifax is lawyer so there's like
three or four layers of garbage here
first is the obvious one right which is
this guy's totally discredited in
advance as an investigator of Equifax
there's every expectation he's going to
have to recuse himself from a bunch of
investigations that are going on
including Equifax including Facebook
he's done some work with Facebook as
well that's layer one second layer is
that yeah on paper he was a lawyer for a
lot of these companies but he wasn't
really a lawyer in the traditional sense
in some of these he was basically a
lawyer in the lobbyists sense for a lot
of companies the companies would go to
Andrew Smith and they'd hire him as a
lawyer but specifically so that he would
help their relationship with the FTC the
Federal Trade Commission to make life
easier for them in their doing business
and then the next layer not surprisingly
with anyone who's Trump connected or
anybody that Trump likes or anybody that
Trump appoints is that Andrew Smith has
also represented some straight-up
amoral bottom feeders like for example a
payday lending moe
named Scott Tucker who was eventually
sentenced to 16 years in prison for
racketeering
so Andrew Smith is without question he's
effectively a corporate lobbyist lawyer
Trump said there was going to be no more
of this lobbyists as part of government
stuff we're gonna drain the swamp get
the revolving door out of there and then
this guy is going to be running one of
the Commission's that's part of the
broader FTC this is regulatory capture
right regulatory capture I've talked
about this term before never as much as
under this administration regulatory
capture is when you've got regulatory
agencies that supposedly exists to be in
the public's interest right they are
supposed to act in the public interest
they get taken over by people working on
the behalf of the industry that's
supposed to be regulated and regulatory
capture is really the hallmark of the
Trump administration look at Ajit pie
right runs the FCC supposed to protect
consumer interests he's a former Verizon
lawyer Rick Perry Secretary of Energy
darling of the fossil fuel industry
Scott Pruett running the EPA
Environmental Protection Agency he used
to sue the EPA because they were doing
too much to protect the environment that
he felt went beyond their roles and
responsibilities he runs the EPA now and
then less well-known as Julian Schmoke
who is running the Department of
Education x' unit that police's fraud in
higher education he used to work for a
for-profit college named DeVry that's
known for very very bad things the
regulatory capture that's going on under
this administration is stunning but you
got to be careful Pat because a lot of
times when we on the Left point out
regulatory capture the anti regulation
small government crowd will say you know
what David you're right we shouldn't
have these regulatory agencies because
of the fact that these swamp fillers are
being brought in and of course that's
not the problem the problem is not that
we have regulatory agencies
it's that industry controls them and
they're not actually doing the
regulation that they're supposed to be
doing so we've got to be careful when we
talk about this to make sure that it's
clear that we're not suggesting not
regulating I think they would argue that
there's a very narrow field of people
who would qualify to be the head of the
TC like with solo conflict right yeah so
they would have to go to someone in the
industry someone working for Equifax
let's say or that any of the most
knowledgeable people they'd like to say
yeah and maybe even alternative wouldn't
be the best like maybe it's a career
bureaucrat but certainly it's better
than someone who's worked in Verizon or
any of these other businesses I think
that's the point which is we need
credible regulation if that actually
controls the power of corporations and
it's really dangerous to say regulatory
capture is bad but the answer is
forgetting about regulation because
businesses have an interest to regulate
themselves anyway which is sort of like
the most laughable talking point at this
point anyway the solution is we have to
dig deeper and solve the problem not
throw the entire idea in the garbage
which is what a lot of so-called small
government conservatives want to do but
it's really really bad out there and of
course Trump doing the exact opposite of
what supposedly he was going to be doing